all right mike uh let's bring in some
company and mike you know it's not every
day
uh that we get an opportunity to hang
out with
with championship stock uh you know dave
roberts
he's got uh he's got a championship ring
on the way
he's going to put it on and he'll come
back on brother and pro brother from
another and to show off the ring
then he's got one in the vault from 2004
from his days with the boston red sox uh
the manager of the
2020 world series champions la dodgers
uh joins us what's going on dave roberts
good to see you fellas what's going on
you know um i'm excited to be a part of
this i love what you guys are doing
and uh just for you two to be creative
for me to be on have a conversation that
can kind of go
anywhere um but yeah uh
winning in 04 in boston as a player was
something
incredible for myself our
my teammates the city of boston and
um you know now winning it in a
in the year of a pandemic as a manager
for the dodgers uh was quite different
and uh just as much uh satisfying so
yeah
i got to come back on bro brother from
another and uh rock
both of my rings because right now i i
got one unlock and then one on the way
so yeah i got to come back
all right see you all right nixon you're
already flexing now but but before we
get into it though like we got to get
into your your little arrangement
because i mean in 2020 you know the zoom
background is everything a lot of people
have libraries
some people have like nice kitchens i
mean
oh my goodness this is so i mean you
know you gotta start with uh
the goat so that's mj and then my
father's uh favorite football player of
all time was gail sarah so i got a
jersey signed by
the great gayle sayers and then i
always love joe montana there's a willie
mays arguably the greatest player of all
time that's my man right there maury
wills
and then i got barry bonds and then
in there is a locker i had built so i
got jersey from
uh there's uh my man derek jeter right
there i got his uh 3
000 hit bat and a bunch of different
jerseys
uh helmet back there so i got a bunch of
crazy stuff fellas
man that's the hangout spot right there
holly
i love that take the shows you got to
have your own stuff on there too
there you go and i see i see jackie back
there too man you got everything
so look dave i can't tell you
i can't say it on the air because of
restrictions
i can't tell you what my reaction was
when i found out
that mookie bets was being traded from
the red sox to the dodgers i can't say
that
i can't say that and stay on the air now
maybe
you can tell me what was it you know
where were you
when you found out it was official you
guys were going to get mookie bets
uh give up some minor leaguers give up a
reserve outfielder and get
the second best player in baseball for
my money uh what was your reaction
no it's like and i know you guys are on
uh you know are on top of the nba and
i'll just give you a quick little
analogy it's like
uh steve kerr's a good buddy of mine and
it's like when it says hey
kd's coming to a dub nation
it's like that's just not supposed to
happen you know you already got a great
team and it's like
what we having a player in his prime
mookie bets coming to the dodgers that
stuff like that just doesn't happen
and the bar for me was already set high
but then when i got a chance to
spend time with mookie and understand uh
what type of man he is a teammate he is
i mean goodness uh we gotta steal uh
acquiring a player like mookie betts
no question and and to re-sign him on
top of that with a lot of people
hoping that he would hit the market yeah
um but speaking of that bar
that was set for you dave i mean
obviously the expectation in la for
years has been championship robust and
you went through
quite a few disappointments before
breaking through this year
and finally getting that title so i
guess given
the journey how much sweeter was it for
you guys
uh to finally get it done in this most
unusual of seasons
on top of all that i'll tell you mike um
the first thing i told our guys this
past spring
uh before we stopped for the summer camp
and the quaran team
i referenced a kobe bryant quote i was
at his last
uh nba game and i said and he said
uh the dream is the journey
and um i just really wanted our players
to understand that the ups the downs the
trials the failures successes
that's a part of it and although we were
still
in a world of world series or bust
we still needed to focus on the journey
and eliminate the noise and expectations
and kind of
put our head down and play good baseball
and i think that
with what happened the start stop uh
you know with the george floyd all the
social injustices that we had to address
which
a lot of our guys really grew up and
became not only
not only were just major league ball
players but really stood up and
for what's right and um i think that
just our ability to focus on
baseball but also take on some other
things that we really
uh weren't prepared for but really
handled amazingly
led to this and i think that now we can
look back and go man
it's pretty special um and uh what's
that uh
john wooden quote um talent wins
championship
but character uh allows you to repeat
so uh i trust our character of the guys
and i look forward to
doing it again next year okay dave
that's great i want to i want to hear
what that was like for
for you all to talk about some of the
social issues that were happening in the
country because i've said before
like all the places i've worked i've
worked with people
who didn't necessarily agree with me
politically
uh we weren't aligned we didn't see uh
things the same way but you know what i
didn't have to do
i didn't have to share a clubhouse with
them i didn't have to travel with them
you know they go home i go home we
didn't share the same planes
but in professional sports baseball
you're around each other all the time
so what were those conversations uh like
because i can't assume that everybody
saw it the same way what was it like for
you
you know what it was it was uh really uh
interesting
uh very difficult and to have those
uncomfortable conversations uh but
needed conversations
and i can speak to our clubhouse you're
talking about a day where major league
baseball players
uh protested a major league baseball
game and yeah you can't speak to
you know one person of color and a
person that doesn't know
that person's plight uh to a person
that's not of color and
everyone can't be the expectation for
everyone to feel the exact same way as
you said michael
is unrealistic but i do believe that
we did a great job and i think baseball
as an industry did a really good job of
listening to uh the people that needed
to be heard
and it wasn't from a place of this is an
angry black man
that's just disgruntled and so i think
that
for clayton kershaw justin turner and
all the rest of our players to stand by
mookie myself
george lombard our first base coach and
say hey
if you're not playing you're not
managing we're not playing
and then what was just as powerful is
the next day
when mookie decided when he was
contemplating and i was contemplating
should we manage
and keep going but he said my white
teammates were in it with me when we
protested
i didn't want to be divisive again by
not playing and
have them play so then what they decided
to do with the players
alliance guys like andrew mccutch and
uh curtis grant and all these different
guys that kind of came together to form
that
players alliance so then now we come
together
white players black players to decide to
play together uh
money is going to be going to
underprivileged kids and in an inner
city and we're going to do something
with this so
it was just pretty amazing to see my
players my coaches
all grow what do you think that that uh
that moment
coupled with we talked about mookie
betts earlier and i mean everybody
who's paid attention i mean he didn't
just get good overnight he's been one of
the premier players in the game for a
lot of years but but seem to take it to
another level on this stage
with this team uh you know this year in
terms of people's awareness of him so
you couple
that with two rookies of the year both
being black players
um you know what more can the game do or
has the game even been doing behind the
scenes
uh since the season to help make the
game
more attractive to young ball players
young black ball players continue to try
to
diversify this game because i imagine
that it's it's pretty challenging having
those conversations when most of the
people
in your industry don't look like you
yeah i'll tell you we as an industry
haven't done a good job
and this is you know probably over
the last 20 years it's gone in the wrong
direction
and um i think uh you know
marketing you know it's kind of chicken
or the egg
what do we need to do first and i think
one thing we need to do is certainly
as an industry players association major
league baseball we need to be
intentional um we need to market the
players
you know i remember and i we see this
michael jordan jersey uh
in the background you know i remember
being a kid and everyone wanted to be
like mike
and and that's where nba marketed the
player and the person and i think that
young black kids just don't see people
like them playing baseball so i think we
got to do a better job marketing
i think we got to spend money in the
inner cities and
get bats balls gloves tighten up the
fields get kids playing baseball
and also in a deeper issue i think that
we've got to
fundamentally reward
players compensate players and make the
game
more uh which shows the skill set
of the black player you know the bunting
the stolen base
the outfield arm these are things that i
remember whether it's reggie smith who's
a good friend of mine
or andre dawson or all these different
black players that i knew growing up ken
griffey jr
they could do it all and uh now it's
about just hitting home runs and a
strikeout and a walk and
it's just not as dynamic as the game
should be
would you say uh it was your talent
that that made you a fan of baseball or
was it your fandom
that got you into baseball what was it
for you as a kid
i think initially it was the talent and
i was one of those kids that
uh played all three sports football
basketball baseball whatever was in
season and nowadays
guys when they're kids when they're you
know girls or boys they
pick a sport you know they're eight nine
ten years old they're
specific to that one sport which i do
think that
has made the skill set better but i
don't think it's a benefit to the kids
um so i think for me it was a talent
because i played all three
but then i grew up in san diego so for
me to see tony gwynn
uh play baseball and i want to be like
tony nguyen i wanted to be like ricky
henderson
and so for me then it became like how
what can i do to be like tony gwynn
or griffey jr or ricky henderson
a major milestone for the game really
for society was kim aang
taking the top job down down in florida
i seen a big smile
uh what'd you think when she got the gig
with the marlins
i was like man we're getting it right
and um this is uh a woman
a person that has been in baseball for
three decades
started from the ground up and uh
started with scouting
and i remember when i was with the
dodger she was an assistant general
manager
and she was a person that was always
around the ball field
watching guys do their extra work and
pick brains of as you see tommy lasorda
dan evans was the general manager at the
time she had a good relationship with
jim tracy our manager then she talked to
the players and
then she went into the major league
baseball office and
guys i'm telling you for a person to
have the grit
determination but not have the
bitterness uh
against the industry where there were
many times she was just being
interviewed as uh
you know just to say she was being
interviewed
just to check a box and there was just
no ill will for her to still
do her job we're both on the major
league baseball diversity committee
and for me i just consider a great
friend and derek is just i mean i showed
you this jersey
he's always been my favorite player but
for him as an executive to hire her
and i don't even think it's going out on
the limb it's the right hire
but she just gets it she's done
everything in baseball and the
the marlins are better for it you said
uh
derek uh is your favorite player uh we
talked about 2004
a little bit before he came on uh major
steel
and old four everybody knew what hey
it's funny here comes dave roberts into
the game he's a pinch runner
everybody knows why he's in the game
he's in the bed he's in the game to
steal second base
you took off and you did it anyway now
jeter tries to get you with this swipe
tag
and you know and people in boston are
used to the yankees getting the benefit
of the doubt
did you ever talk to him about hey man
it was closer you made it look closer
than it was did you ever think it was
going to be
called anything but safe so um i
so i got a couple little things so right
there i come in and safe and then uh
derek as he always does you know he pats
the guy and does a little walk back and
he just said
how the f did you just do that
and just like a little smirk and uh
another quick story is so that was 2004
in 2005
no it was 2007. i ended up going with
the uh
signing with the giants san francisco
giants and on opening day
we played the dodgers and uh joe
torrey was the manager of the dodge at
the time so we're going to the lines to
meet
and joe torre just looks at me and waves
his index fee and goes
i remember you and just kind of gave me
what's up uh listen back we could talk
to you all day but uh we appreciate you
being so generous with your time
last one for me is i just i know we're
in a pandemic and so you know and
obviously you know california especially
you know it's been uh most people been
you know inside and you know
on lockdown and rightfully so but is
there a great interaction
a great story even a great phone call
zoom meeting whatever
since you have been a world series
winning manager
that you can share with us i told you
before you got two cities now that
you'll never pay for a meal in
boston and l.a which is not bad it's
pretty good dining but since you brought
it home for the dodgers
give me your best story from the off
season
um the best um okay
so um we haven't had that chance to
celebrate yet
um and i'm still hoping for a laker
dodger
parade all throughout the city of uh los
angeles
you got a.d lebron coach vogel
and then you got kershaw bets all these
guys right
but i had a call from sandy koufax
which was just uh ridiculous
and just kind of congratulating me and
how we did it
uh vince scully uh is insane
um i just i've got so many of those like
random great people just hit me up
uh congratulating me so very humble very
blessed
man what a history what a history uh for
the dodgers
you know you you mentioned some of those
guys vin scully been there uh you know
sandy koufax
uh and and just like your story too i
and before we let you go i just want to
congratulate you because i wonder
if it started to play some mind games
with you you guys kept winning was it
eight straight
um division titles that you won yeah we
won eight straight so uh
you know we've earned that target on our
back that's what you play for right
so uh yeah and i expect to do it again
next year
um but you guys are the best and uh one
last thing is
you guys talked about what we can do for
uh as far as getting uh more black
players playing uh baseball
i challenge you guys to keep uh bringing
us uh black players
coaches managers on your show and let's
talk baseball too because we all love
the nfl the nba but uh let's talk
baseball too all right
well you definitely got it you and
anybody you know got to definitely
definitely got to open invitation that's
right
that's yeah open open invitation
dave i'll tell you this this last thing
before we let you go uh
my nephew he gets so tired of me talking
about this
his baseball moment uh it was in 2002
ricky henderson was
like playing out the string he was with
the red sox at the time so i took him to
fenway park
he asked me my nephew did he was like
five or six years old
what's a steal at that moment
ricky henderson stole second base i said
it's that
and that's what got him hooked on
baseball i'm serious
it's just the thing is that when i just
love it when mookie betts or ricky
henderson is up to bat
then he gets on first base and then the
focus stays on them when they get to
first base
and then they start creating tension and
people get on the edge of their seats
and that guy back there maury wheels did
the same thing
where i used to hear stories about
people the whole stadium would say
go go go go and it's like that's the
stuff the game inside the game
that uh i want to bring back because you
know i'm biased to the stolen base
fantastic hey dave hey you always always
have a seat here come back any time
just love to catch up on the call just
show up just just shut up
you guys are doing it man all the best
thank you hey thanks for watching
brother from another on youtube
make sure you hit subscribe before you
leave and be sure to watch us
3 to 5 p.m eastern time on peacock
appreciate you